this is a production of cornell
university
okay so cucumber or cucumber sativas and
melon cucumbers milo
belonged to the cucurbitaceae family and
i know that this group knows that the
cucurbitaceae family includes many high
value and nutritionally important crops
cucumbers melons watermelons summer and
winter squashes
pumpkins and gourds and while it doesn't
have all the wonderful genomic tools
that arabidopsis has
cucurbits are beautiful and they taste
great and they can be
really bizarre cucumbers exhibit
tremendous developmental plasticity
and fruit size and shape and pattern and
they're also
extremely sexually flexible
so our primary interests are sex
expression during floral development
and fruit development especially early
fruit development
growth and expansion phases
so cucurbit species and genotypes within
species
exhibit a wide array of heritable sex
types
with varying combinations of either male
or female
or bisexual flowers these underlying sex
types can then be modified either by
external
fact environmental factors or the
application of hormones
so if we think about sex expression at
any given node
along the vine of a cucurbit plant
that's going to result from the
underlying genotype of the plant
the environment the developmental stage
of the plant
hormone balance and environment
now cucurbits are typically either
monitious or andromedias
monitors means you have separate male
and female flowers on the same plant
andrew monicius would be you have male
flowers and bisexual flowers
on the same plant in addition there
tends to be a developmental pattern for
expression of these sex phenotypes
so if we're looking at cucumber which is
monicious you would begin with a series
of vegetative nodes along the main stem
followed by nodes that produce only male
flowers
followed by nodes that produce both male
and
female flowers on the other hand for
the andromedia's melon analogously you
would have vegetative nodes male nodes
and then nodes that produce combination
of bisexual
plus male notes so despite the fact
that these plants can produce unisexual
flowers
either only male or only female at early
stages of development
all four whorls typical of a bisexual
flower will be initiated
so you'll have sepals and petals and
stables stamen
and carpal primordia all get initiated
now this is from cucumber if we look at
male buds
we see the initiation of the standard
primordia and the very beginning
of carpal primordia but then as the
flower develops or the bud
develops we see growth and
differentiation of the stamen primordia
but the carpal primordia don't really do
anything
in contrast if we look at what will
become a female bud
we see the stamen primordial looking
similar to the male
and then the beginnings of the
development of the carpal primordia
as that moves forward in time the carpal
primordia continues to develop it
develops ovaries and ovules
but the stamens are arrested in
development
in addition numerous studies with
exogenous hormones
have indicated that ethylene is the
primary hormonal determinant of sex
in these species in species such as
cucumber
melon and squash ethylene will promote
femaleness so if you spray a plant with
ethylene you'll get more carpal bearing
buds
while inhibiting either ethylene
production or perception
for example spraying with silver nitrate
you will increase
maleness recently key sex expression
genes have been cloned both from melon
and cucumber
and they have been shown to encode an
ethylene production enzyme
acs or acc synthase which is one of the
key steps
in ethylene production so for example in
cucumber
female lines that produce only female
flowers have an extra copy
of this acs gene in melon
those lines that are capable of
converting their bisexual flowers to
become just female
also express an additional acs
so it has been proposed that sex
determination in these developing floral
buds
results for a combination of ethylene
production
and ethylene perception by relevant
floral primordia at critical times
in development so our questions were can
we identify critical sites for ethylene
perception or production
within the developing floral bud that
are responsible
for sex determination and can we use
that knowledge
about the role of ethylene at critical
developmental points
to either increase or cause earlier
carpal bearing bud formation
and like was just said to you earlier if
you care about fruit production of
course you care about
female flowers or carpal bearing flowers
so in order to ask can we identify
critical sites for ethylene production
within the developing floral bud that
are responsible for sex determination
we took advantage of a gene from
arabidopsis the mutant etr-1-1 gene
this produces a protein that inhibits
ethylene perception and it is a dominant
negative
inhibitor of perception and we introduce
this gene
under control of one of three promoters
either the standard cauliflower mosaic
virus 35s promoter that drives
expression
strong constitutive expression the crc
or krabs claw
promoter which in arabidopsis targets
expression in developing
carpals and nectary primordia or the a
pedal 3 promoter
which in arabidopsis drives expression
in developing stamen
and petal primordia
now we had predicted that if we inhibit
because we know if we spray silver
nitrate and inhibit perception
will inhibit carpal bearing blood
formation so we predicted that if we
constitutively inhibit ethylene
perception that we would lose carpal
bearing flowers
we also predicted that if we inhibited
perception
in the carpal primordia that we would
inhibit
development of carpal bearing buds but
if that we inhibited
perception in the stamen primordia we
would not have an
effect on the floral development
so first then we did transformation of
melon using agrobacterium mediated
transformation of cotyledon explants
we regenerated our plants produced
progeny verified that we had introduced
the genes with the appropriate promoters
that we
expected and that they were being
expressed as we expected
looking first at the 35s or constitutive
expression
we wanted to know that if we took that
ethylene
the gene inhibiting ethylene perception
in arabidopsis that it indeed would
inhibit
ethylene perception in melon and we were
able to see several phenotypes
that confirmed this for example the
transgenics were very inhibited and
rooting
as people had observed with ethylene
inhibition
they also showed a delay and abscission
of the floral buds
from the pedicels we also saw an
increase
in ethylene production this also
is standard for etr-1-mutants or other
ethylene perception mutants
they're unable to perceive the ethylene
normally if they perceive the ethylene
there would be feedback inhibition
in the level of ethylene produced now
they don't know so you see an
increase in ethylene produced so this
convinced
us that the gene the etr-1 gene from
arabidopsis was capable of
inhibiting ethylene perception in melon
plants
what effect did it have on sex
this graph shows nodes along the main
stem
these are wild-type vellums and also
non-transgenic
segregates and from there we see
initially
vegetative nodes followed by nodes that
produce only male flowers
followed by nodes that produce either
bisexual or male flowers
as we would expect but when we look at
the
transgenic etr-1-1 melons we see that
the great majority about 86 percent of
them
never produced a carpal bearing node
there were a few plants that produce one
or two and then returned only to
producing male flowers
so this indicates that ethylene
perception is indeed critical
for the production of carpal bearing
buds
so the next question is where in that
floral primordia is perception
essential now recall we had predicted
that if we inhibit perception in the
carpal primordia
we would inhibit carpal formation but if
we inhibited perception in the stamen
primordia
we did not expect that that would have
an effect
what we observed was exact opposite
if we inhibited perception in the stamen
primordia
we essentially eliminated any production
of carpal bearing buds
but if we inhibited perception in the
carpal primordia
not only did we fail to inhibit carpal
bearing blood formation
we actually saw somewhat of an increase
and i'll come back to that in a moment
so after we were done scratching our
heads
going back and retesting all the plants
and making sure we hadn't confused which
line was which and which had the right
promoters
when we started to the first conclusion
had to be that ethylene perception by
stamen or petal primordia is necessary
for carpal development now this starts
to make sense
the stamen primordia are initiated
before the carpal primordia
so that means that they would be present
to perceive ethylene in time
to make a decision about whether or not
to allow the carpals to develop
this is also consistent with the
observation
that inhibition of carpal formation in a
male flower
occurs at an earlier stage of
development than does inhibition of
stamens
in what will become a female flower so
this also suggests then that there's
crosstalk going on
between these developing sex organs
now i mentioned i would come back to why
did we see
increased carpal bearing blood formation
in
the um lines that had inhibition of
perception
in those in the carpal primordia
well if we look at the abysses of those
plants what we see is an increase in
ethylene production
remember i indicated that you inhibit
perception you can get an increase in
ethylene production
so the carpals are not perceiving we get
an increase in production but the
stamens
can still perceive so they perceive the
ethylene
that could lead to an increase in the
carpal bearing blood production
in addition we saw a further phenotype
and that is remember typically we would
have a bisexual flower
so you would have stamens as well as
carpels present but in these in the crc
etr 1-1 lines
approximately 50 percent of the buds and
the flowers
saw a complete loss of stamens
essentially they became female
so again if you have this elevated
ethylene the
plants the plants go on to produce
carpal bearing buds
but then that elevated ethylene can
subsequently lead to an inhibition of
stamens
that's what happens naturally when you
have
plants that are capable of producing
female flowers you have that expression
in case of melon you would have the
acs-7 gene
that comes on later in development and
causing the inhibition
of the stamens
so collectively these observations
provide new insight into the sex
determination process
and interaction between the organ
primordia they suggest that the critical
site for ethylene perception at the time
of sex determination
resides within the stamen or petal
primordia and conversely
the inhibition of stamen production
results from ethylene production by the
carpal primordia
this occurs naturally through the acs-7
gene
in melon and in our case using crc etr
1-1
furthermore this reciprocal relationship
would then assure
that at least one sex is expressed i
that you don't inhibit your stamens
until you know you've got carpals being
produced
so we then want to look at where what
was happening with regard to ethylene
production
so in this case we used the acs or that
first committed step
in ethylene production and hooked it up
to the same set of promoters
as i described earlier if we look at it
with 35s we verified that there was
production
and that that expression of the acs gene
was capable
of driving increased ethylene production
that also led as we would predict to an
increased number of bisexual buds and
flowers and an earlier appearance of the
first bisexual flower on the main stem
so this is consistent with the predicted
effect of increased ethylene production
if we now targeted that acs gene
to carpal or sorry to stamen primordia
we saw a very dramatic effect on
femaleness
here again is the wild type showing
vegetative nodes followed by male nodes
followed by a mix the nodes that have a
mixture of either bisexual or male nodes
but in those lines for which ethylene
production was targeted
to the stamen primordia we saw a very
dramatic change we saw a complete
loss of the male only phase and we saw
the appearance
of a bisexual only phase that does not
normally occur
in wild-type plants a subset of those
individuals actually showed a complete
conversion they never produced male
flowers only produced biosexual flowers
essentially became hermaphrodite plants
now when we look we did see an increase
in the number of carpal bearing buds and
carpal bearing flowers
but even more dramatic than the increase
in carpal bearing flowers was actually a
loss
in the number of male buds and flowers
so that if we look at the total we
actually feel total buds
reduced in the transgenic relative to
the wild type lines
this loss of buzz especially at the
earliest stages that we could see
suggests early but abortion and what it
may reflect
is the effect of ethylene inhibiting
stamen development
early now the stamens themselves are the
ones producing ethylene
they they would perceive it immediately
and you would have the potential then to
inhibit that statement development
prior to the initiation of carpal
development in at least in some of those
cases
that would lead to the cause asexual
buds that might then be subject to
abortion
and we're currently doing the microscopy
to verify this view
if we express in the carpal primordia we
did not see an effect
on sex expression so the ethylene
production experiments provide further
support for a key role of stamen
primordia and sex determination the
increased endogenous ethylene production
caused an increase in carpal bearing
buds and a reduction or loss
of male only phase and that we suggest
that the increased ethylene production
by the stamen primordia
may lead to a loss of those initial
stamens further implicating the
importance of crosstalk between the
developing sex organs to assure
that you have one or the other sex organ
present
so we also wanted to ask can we use any
of this information to either get
increased carbon blood formation or
earlier carpal bearing blood formation
maybe we could shorten the growing
season or get melons on the market
sooner
so to do this we needed to do field
trials
and first we looked at 35s acs plants
and these plants as consistent with what
we observed in the greenhouse had
earlier appearance
of first bisexual flowers increase in
the number of total bisexual flowers on
the main stem
and earlier appearance of first fruit by
approximately
10 nodes on the main stem if we looked
at ripening if we
take took a harvest date such as this
example
we saw that there was earlier ripening
occurring in these
fruits such that at this time point the
only lines that had either over ripe
or ripe fruits were the two transgenic
lines
now this might be due to earlier fruit
set but of course it also could be due
to constituent expression of ethylene
which can influence ripening as well
we cannot separate those effects in this
experiment
we also looked at the crc etr-1-1 melons
and again we saw earlier occurrence of
the first carpel bearing flower on the
main stem
increased number of flowers and as we
had seen in the greenhouse we also saw
conversion of approximately 50 percent
of the bisexual flowers to become
female we also saw an increase in
initial fruit set on the plant by
approximately 63 percent
relative to the non-transgenic lines but
that decreased
as we went through the season likely
reflecting increased
abortion of these young fruit
at the end when we got to harvest size
fruit there was only about a 25 percent
increase in the transgenic lines
relative to wild type
if we looked at harvestable yield per
plot it was essentially constant
across all of the lines and what we see
is that that increased fruit number was
counterbalanced by an approximately
25 decrease in the average fruit weight
for these melons
with respect to ripening the crc etr
lines showed mixed phenotypes
one showed increased percent of fruit at
full slip so increased ripening
and that would be consistent with
earlier fruit set and possible effective
ethylene
but one line on the other appeared to
have a delay in ripening it did not
turn orange and its fruit did not reach
full slip
and it appeared to have did not undergo
this m15 line did not show a normal
ripening progression
so if we're looking at a our wild type
melon we're going from green to turning
to ripe and then eventually overripe
where you see degradation of the flesh
and
separation of seeds on the other hand if
we look at many of our crc
m15 fruit they remain green on the
outside they do not upsize from the
peduncle
yet when you open them up there is
degradation of the flesh
and detachment of the seeds
we look at internal fruit ethylene in
that one line
that did show the accelerated um
trend as we would have expected the m5
fruits their ethylene production for
green and ripe fruits
was as you would expect comparable to
wild type
but those from the m15 line where we had
the external green but internal
ripening phenomenon we see that the
green fruits that on the outside appear
unripe were actually having ethylene
levels comparable
to ripe fruit
so can we use this knowledge to
increase carpal bearing flower
production or early increase to earlier
fruit production
well both lines caused increased carpal
bearing flower production and fruit set
however the increased roots that was
compensated for by reduced fruit size
did not result in increased yield and
the effects of ripening and potential
earliness
were a variable among the lines and may
reflect expression levels
and patterns
the other area of interest is fruit
development especially early fruit
growth
and expansion and we know that cucurbit
fruits show extreme morphological
variation have tremendous capacity for
rapid growth
there are record-setting pumpkins that
are three-quarters of a ton for an
individual fruit
watermelons have been recorded to have
peak growth of half a kilogram per day
in field conditions and cucumbers maybe
they're not as exciting but they can
still be highly variable
so if we look at this immense diversity
in cucumber fruit shape and size
it implies that they're either novel
genes or gene combinations
or gene regulation capable of
controlling fruit growth and development
so we're taking two approaches to study
early cucumber fruit growth
the first is a qtl based analysis in
collaboration with colleagues in israel
amir
sherman and ron ophir and wisconsin ikun
wang
as well as transcriptome analysis of
early fruit development
so fruit development typically includes
four phases
development of the ovary then following
pollination there would be cell division
cell expansion and then maturation and
ripening
cucumber fruits exhibit a typical
sigmoidal pattern
of fruit growth with cell division
generally occurring in about the first
five days post pollination then an
exponential increase in fruit size from
about four to twelve days post
pollination
and then a period of maturation and
ripening but cucumbers are harvested
as immature typically at about eight to
twelve days post pollination
unlike if we were looking at melons or
tomatoes we would be out
at this mature and ripening stage
the increase in fruit size is largely
driven by an increase in cell size
here we see an approximately 20-fold
increase in mesocarp cell size from
4 to 12 days post-pollination
and that increase in cell size the cells
become highly evacuated
and we see a decrease in cell wall
thickness we also see an increase in
cell size
in the exocarp cells but in that case it
also includes an increase
in cell wall and middle lamella
thickness
so to perform the qtl analysis this a 45
000
point snip array spanning the cucumber
genome is currently
being developed by ronophir and amir
sherman to allow for qtl
mapping and this is being done based on
the availability of two
sequenced cucumber lines with dramatic
differences in fruit size and shape
the first is chinese long 9930 this was
the first published cucumber genome
sequence
by huang ital from the beijing genomics
institute
and the second was sequenced by equine
wang and all in collaboration with rosh
454
this was a chinese ginishas pickling
cucumber line
wang also his group also made f7 real
populations
crosses derived from gy14 the pickling
type by the chinese lawn
so as a starting point to identify
separable qtl
all that can contribute to these
differences in fruit size and shape
we sought to identify growth parameters
that differ between the two cultivars
so factors that we're looking at
includes ovule number cell number at
anthesis
increase in cell number post anthesis
period of cell division
period of cell expansion cell size cell
shape and preferred plane of cell
division
we can see that differences in ovary
size and shape are as parent as early
between the chinese long and the
pickling type as seven
days pre-anthesis indicating the
importance of early development factors
influencing ovary shape and in this case
ovary length
here there was a significant difference
in over length at
seven days pre thesis and that
difference continued to occur
until we hit anthesis where the chinese
long
were much longer than the pickling type
both of the cucumber fruits exhibited a
typical sigmoidal
growth pattern and as we can expect we
see an increase in cell number
preceding the increase in fruit and cell
size
if we look at length and diameter in
comparison to each other among
segregating f2 progeny
we see that they are not correlated
indicating that the factors deriving
driving increase in fruit length are
separable
from those driving fruit diameter
there is also a difference in overall
number with the chinese long
approximately twice as many as the
pickling type and f1 falling almost
immediately in between if we look for a
correlation between ovule number
and fruit length we see that that is
correlated but there's no correlation
with fruit diameter indicating that
ovule number is a strong determinant of
over a length
but not diameter
if we look at cell number in
longitudinal section we see that at
anthesis the chinese lung already had a
greater number of cells
and post anthesis there continues to be
an increase in cell number for a longer
period cell division is occurring
longer than in the pickling type
cell size however is essentially
equivalent between the two
in contrast if we look at ovary diameter
just like we saw with ovary length
the chinese lung at seven days
pre-enthusiast was lot
bigger than the pickling type but as we
approached in thesis instead of that
difference getting bigger
that difference actually disappeared and
post pollination we see that the
increase in diameter was much
faster for the pickling type than the
chinese long
if we look at increase in cell number we
see that there was a
more rapid and a longer period of cell
division occurring in cross section for
the
pickling type than chinese lung leading
to a three-fold greater cell number
in the pickling type in diameter
the two lines also exhibited differences
in cell shape gy14
cell size was pretty much equivalent
whether you're looking at longitudinal
cross-sections
whereas there was a difference in the
dimensions for the
chinese law so collectively these
results indicate that there are several
factors pre
and post anthesis influencing fruit size
and shape the number of ovules
the number of cells in longitudinal
section or cross-section
the length of period of cell division
and either fruit elongation or fruit
with expansion
post-pollination and cell shape
so these observations suggest that there
are distinct traits that we can now
analyze in the real
population for future qtl analysis
and finally i'd like to talk about our
work studying transcriptome
analysis of early fruit development and
for this a set of three fruit growth
analysis experiments was performed in
the greenhouse
we wanted to be able to monitor changes
in gene expression
and relate those to obvious stages in
fruit development
one of the things is that typically
people look at that initial stage it's
not very interesting
you know the fruit set and then they
kind of grow and then they do the
exciting stuff at the end if they're
going to ripen they make flavors and
aromas and colors
but when we started to look carefully at
what's happening during that early stage
of growth in cucumbers
there actually is a lot happening
there's a highly reproducible
progression
of changes and features including a loss
of ridges
the formation and then subsidence
of warts the development and then
incision
of spines changes in wax coverage and
chlorophyll content and patterns and
placenta and seed development
another interesting feature during early
cucumber
fruit development is important with
respect to infection by the important oh
my seat pathogen phytophthora capsacy
from some work that we had been done to
try to screen for
cucumber fruits that were resistant to
this pathogen
for breeding purposes at that time we
were not
successful in identifying a source of
resistance for breeding
however we did discover that there was a
developmental
progression in resistance or an
age-related resistance to this disease
such that young fruit are very highly
susceptible and they become resistant
as they develop and this transition from
susceptible to resistance
was directly correlated with that
transition away from the period
of rapid fruit elongation
so collectively these observations show
that there's a lot of changes occurring
during early fruit development and they
provide a physiological context
from which to examine changes in gene
expression
so to perform the transcriptomic
analysis fruits were sampled at 0
4 8 12 and 16 days post pollination
this allowed us to cover that
exponential period of growth
and also include the time at which
cucumber fruits would typically
be harvested rna and cdna libraries were
prepared for samples that included
pericarp and placenta but did not
include seeds
454 pyro sequencing provided
approximately 1.1 million ests or
approximately 200
000 clean reads per time point and
approximately 82
of those could be assembled into a set
of about 28 000 contigs
the mean contig length was 834 and the
mean number of reads per content was 67.
now one of the first things we wanted to
do was look at the relationship between
the number of reads
and our ability to assemble context of
course you would imagine as you have
more reads you can put together a longer
context
but at some point you're going to reach
the full transcript length and it's not
going to get any longer
so if we look at that we see a steady
increase in the average contact length
as our number of reads increases
but it then leveled off at about 1400
base pairs that's a typical transcript
length that's what we would expect
and that occurred at approximately 30
ests per contig
we also asked what was the relationship
between the number of reads and our
ability
to identify putative homologues in the
databases
and we could see with arabidopsis that
it also steadily increased
and then leveled off at about 30 reads
per contig
and so we then used 30 ests per contig
as a baseline
for our subsequent bioinformatic
analysis
now at the at the point where we leveled
off
approximately 90 percent of our contigs
had putative homologs in arabidopsis
and if we look at the putative
functional assignments of those
genes we see that they fall into a
distribution pretty similar to what you
would see in arabidopsis within about
two-fold
range for the or the categories in
rabidoxis suggesting good representation
of the genome but there were 10 percent
that did not have putative homologues in
arabidopsis
now approximately five percent
approximately half of those did have
putative homologues in other speeches
such as grape and popular for which
their extensive
gene bank entries but the final five
percent either did not have identified
homologues
in the current database or they only had
homologues in other
cucurbit species suggesting that these
may be
unique to cucumber or other cu turbines
relative to the kinds of plant species
that have been sequenced today
if we then looked at the distribution of
these
transcripts that did not have putative
homologues
we see that that was not equivalent at
the different time points
so there were approximately twice as
many that did not have
putative homologs in arabidopsis at 8 12
and 16 days post pollination
as at zero and four days suggesting that
that post fruit set that exponential
growth phase
may include more cucurbit novel genes
if we look at those transcripts
represented by greater than 30 ests
but that had homologues only identified
in cucurbit species
that included about 18 that had putative
functional assignments
and of those eight were related to
phloem
such as slow filament protein phloem
lectin etc and this is consistent with
the unique
phloem structure in cucurbits relative
to other species
we then asked wanted to look at the
relationship
between the genes expressed at the
different ages using principal component
analysis
and this cl put the different ages into
three groups
zero and four days post pollination
eight days post pollination
and twelve and sixteen days post
pollination
can then superimpose that on the growth
curve
and we see that zero and four is that
early fruit set cell division phase
eight peak exponential growth 12 and 16
late or post exponential growth
we next want to be able to do
comparisons between gene expression at
the different ages and this is based on
the assumption
that the number of reads that we're
seeing is actually reflective of the
transcript level
and we were comforted
in two ways with respect to that
question one was that if we looked at
samples
um from eight days post pollination two
sequencing runs we see a very good
correlation
between those suggesting that those that
have low level expression indeed have
low expression
those that have high have high
expression and then we went on to select
a subset of approximately 20 genes that
had differing levels of expression at
each of the time points
and for those we did qrt pcr analysis
we saw good correspondence between the
454 data
and the qrt pcr data and that qrt pcr
analysis was actually performed on two
sets of experiments that had been
done in the greenhouse at different
times so we saw a good correspondence
between the two
sets of qrt indicating good biological
confirmation or reproducibility as well
we then looked at which of those
constructs or sorry which of the
transcripts were most
highly represented specifically at one
age not ones that are highly represented
all the way across
but are there ones that are uniquely
high what's blasting at zero or four
or at eight so if we look at zero and
four we see that there's a
those that are blasting include histones
and ribosome associated proteins
that makes sense these cells are
undergoing cell division they need to
have dna replication they need to have
lots of protein synthesis
histones pretty much disappear by the
time you get to eight days there's a
little carryover
on the ribosomal but what's most
striking however
is that we look at eight days post
pollination we see that more than half
52 of those genes either had unknown
function
or did not have either did not have
homologs in rabidoxis
or if they did we don't know what they
do so this large
proportion of contents without homologs
or with unknown function
may reflect either cucurbit unique genes
or less extensive characteristic
characterization of the exponential
growth phase
if we then look at that group that was
very highly expressed at eight days post
pollination
and we compare that to predicted
arabidopsis homologs
what we see is very different from that
earlier slide i just showed you
this is where everything else fell
within a two-fold range
but here we see that there are some
groups that are very highly
over-represented
and these were typically associated with
cell structure
so for example we see very high level of
expression of aquaporins
be necessary for water uptake to derive
cell expansion
other examples would be the phloem
related proteins which would be
necessary for import of photoassimilate
as well as some of the structural
proteins such as actins or alpha
tubulins
some of the other categories that were
highly expressed were genes associated
with cell walls
again you would expect that for growth
as well as several hormone-associated
genes including
a key enzyme and brassinosteroid
biosynthesis
and brass and steroids have been shown
to be critical for cucumber fruit set in
early development
and they can induce cucumber fruit
growth
another category that was very highly
expressed was latex
associated proteins and lipid associated
proteins
well that was looking at things that are
just blasting what's
really highly expressed at each of these
time points but we're also interested in
genes that may not be expressed
that strongly but still show a very
specific time point of expression
so in order to get a look at that what
we did was we said
let's normalize according to the
proportion of expression
so if a gene was expressed at the same
level throughout this period of
development there are five time points
and you'd see
twenty percent of expression at each of
those ages
so now for example let's look at eight
days post pollination
let's take all of the genes and say what
percentage
of their transcripts occurred at eight
days
and what we see is a very strong
curve with a peak almost exactly at
twenty percent
indicating that the majority of genes
had twenty percent of their expression
at that time point
however we can also see that there's a
long tail
similarly if we look at zero plus four
now you've got two time points together
you'd expect forty percent
or twelve percent plus sixteen and again
they fell at exactly
forty percent so then we asked
what's happening though in these tails
the top
2.5 of genes
can we identify transcripts that were
are specifically enriched
and so what we get here is three
non-overlapping sets of transcripts
0 and 4 8 or 12 and 16
and not only are they not overlapping
with each other but in large part
it was a new set of genes because
earlier we were looking at the most
highly expressed
they had to be at least 0.1 percent on
average they would have been
1700 to 2000 reads per transcript
now we're looking at ones that are on
average 100 to 200
reads per transcript
when we perform functional analysis we
see different kinds of
genes showing enhancement at the
different age groups
so for example at zero and four days we
see an increase as we saw
earlier with cell organogenesis
biogenesis dna and rna metabolism
and here's an example here what we're
looking at is several putative cell
division related genes cyclin and
cyclin-dependent kinases
we see very high expression at zero and
four and then essentially
no expression after that
another example of something that was
uniquely expressed at a specific time
point are several lipid associated
proteins
gl sf motate lipases
lipid transfer proteins and this
actually corresponds
with the time period in which we're
seeing both increase in cuticle
thickness and change in cuticle
structure
if we looked at those that are more
enriched at 12 and 16 days post
pollination
we say that these had the highest
represented representation of abiotic
and biotic stress-related genes
including a variety of heat shock redox
ethylene related transcripts
suggesting a change in emphasis from
growth and defense
from growth to defense
so in conclusion the contig set suggests
broad representation of the cucumber
transcriptome
approximately five percent of the highly
expressed transcripts did not have a
match
or only matched cucurbit clones
suggesting that there may be genes
unique to cucurbits principal component
analysis
placed the ages in three groups zero and
four
days plus pollination characterized by
cell division
and transcripts most highly expressed
included genes associated with cell
division
organogenesis and biogenesis at eight
days post pollination we're at
peak exponential growth highly enriched
for transcripts associated with cell
structure
growth lipid metabolism and defense
and also highly very highly expressed
genes that did not have homologs or
unknown function and finally at 12 and
16 days post pollination the late or
post-exponential growth
exhibited increased expression of
stress-related and environmental
response and extracellular associated
genes
so collectively these patterns of
expression are consistent with a profile
of early
rapid growth followed by an emphasis on
defense
and with that i want to make sure to
acknowledge the people who actually do
the work
graduate student the postdoc calorie
andy and mariah mccauley worked on fruit
development
sex expression katarina papadopoulos
holly little and jessica taft
and the great majority of our melon
transformation is done by our technician
sue hammer as well as thank you to the
agencies that have supported the work
thank you
yeah i was curious in the end uh
you didn't identify any transformation
oh actually there
yeah there are lots of transcription
factors in there they obviously
um don't show up in the most highly
expressed category but we've got lots
and lots of transcription factors
there's so many intricate developmental
things going on
yeah yeah yeah we do have lots
but they're not we were at this point
focusing on the more highly expressed
kinds of genes judy going back to your
sex expression work um the acs
gene has anyone looked at diversity
within that gene across
the german positive to see if there's
evidence for selection
because i
you're talking about the enzymatic
activity or
expression or
just raw nucleotide diversity um
what has been done so far not by us so
for example
the there was a french group that cloned
the different acs genes
and the one from melon what they had
done was
looking at different sex types and then
pulling out
extremes so for example the acs-7 gene
in a plant that's capable of producing
female flowers is functional
but the acs-7 gene in this
one we work with which is bisexual it
still produces that gene we can detect
with
qrt we can detect expression of that
gene but it's a non-functional enzyme
it has a mutation in an active site
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu